but um yeah I've done Street interviews
I've done
um live shows I've done reaction video
I've done like pretty much any type of
content you could name I've probably
done it at some point right I also had a
tick tock I almost had a million
followers on Tick Tock with an 80 female
and I took it down yeah they took me
down I used to do relationship content
with my ex-boyfriend I used to I
literally have done Vlogs I've done
everything okay but you feel like now
this is gonna be the thing you primarily
stick with I mean it's doing you so well
might as well yeah I mean I'd like to do
more like one-on-one interviews in the
future but yeah I mean I love what I do
it's a lot of fun